Und starten das Game nochmal.
Und dann hoffen wir, dass das Ganze funktioniert.
Ich wollte das eigentlich schon viel früher streamen.
Aber ich bin auf die glorreiche Idee gekommen.
Ich lege mich mittags einfach mal kurz hin.
Ich habe jetzt gepennt.
Das war nicht so eine gute Idee.
Ich bin jetzt auch noch voll im Arsch.
Mal gucken, wie gut das läuft.
Was? Moment.
Was will das Game jetzt?
Achso, ja, das ist das übliche.
Das, was es immer anzeigt.
Was?
Ah, Simba oder Nico spielt Overwatch.
Wo hast du denn das gesehen?
Streamt der auch?
So, auf geht's.
Ich bin auch voll im Arsch irgendwie.
Ich meine, ihr kennt das vielleicht,
wenn man gerade frisch aufgestanden ist.
Dann ist man auch so
irgendwie kaputt.
So, ich weiß auch nicht.
Eigentlich müsste ich jetzt erstmal eine Runde rumrennen,
dass ich wieder wach werde irgendwie.
Keine Ahnung.
Lull.
Was?
Ich weiß nicht, was das sagt, aber echt.
Wo ist mein Mauszeiger?
Was?
Die haben echt Overwatch zusammen gespielt,
Sembaro.
Nicht schlecht.
Und?
Wie haben sie sich so geschlagen?
Habt ihr eigentlich schon Cheater gesichtet?
So mal eine Frage.
Ich habe heute auf Twitter gelesen,
die ersten Leute,
ich muss mal kurz nebenbei Kopfhörer entwirren.
Ich hoffe, man hat das gesprochen.
So ist besser.
Ich habe heute auf Twitter gelesen,
die ersten Leute haben das Game schon zurückgegeben.
Ich werde das Game,
nicht zurückgeben.
Ich gebe das Game erst,
ich gebe das Game höchstens zurück.
Ähm.
Was?
Hä?
Ja, woher weißt du denn,
dass der Neko Overwatch spielt?
Ähm, ich werde das Game höchstens zurückgeben,
wenn es Cheater gibt.
Also jetzt innerhalb der ersten paar Tage.
Aber ich bin immer noch so richtig kaputt irgendwie.
Erstmal aufwachen.
Jetzt bräuchte ich meinen Boxsack hier.
Der steht aber drüben.
Könnte ich ein bisschen drauf rumhauen.
Dann wäre ich wach.
Lull.
So, auf geht's.
Jetzt müssen wir uns erstmal diesen tollen Social Hub angucken.
Hier ist ganz schön was los.
Und ich habe irgendwo Rewards, glaube ich, die ich einsammeln kann.
Wir payen Respekt.
Ich habe fast das Gefühl gehabt,
die wollten sich selbst verarschen mit,
dass man F drücken muss bei dem Typ.
Auf der anderen Seite glaube ich das auch wiederum nicht.
Ich habe fast das Gefühl gehabt, die wollten sich selbst verarschen mit, dass man F drücken muss bei dem Typ.
Moment.
Wo konnte man den Scheiß nochmal abgeben?
Ähh..
Bei..
ups
Aber wow, hier ist richtig was los.
Jetzt könnt ihr euch auch daran erinnern.
Bei..
bei Release, da war hier nichts.
Fun goat.
Hier sieht man natürlich auch schön,
was die anderen für Supplycken-Commands gekriegt haben.
Wir werfen jetzt auch mal unsere Supply drops hierhin.
Einfach weil's geht.
Guckt mal was wir da raus bekommen.
Ad gibt Obsch Family zu dieser Seele.
This is our krautprodu biz 크 gut weg.
Extras are there.
Was habe ich da jetzt von?
Kann man sich das irgendwie angucken?
Man kann draufklicken, aber
es passiert nichts, wenn man draufklickt.
Das ist auch toll.
Supply droppen wir mal weiter.
Ich muss hier mal weg.
Es sind mir zu viele Leute am Start.
Bist dich, Alter.
Ex-Supply-Drop. Ach, den darf man denn hier nicht hinlegen?
Ah, die Supply-Drops,
die muss man hier vorne hinlegen,
dass es auch schön viele Leute sehen.
Ähm, ernst, wie
ist das Hobby-Modus?
Epic! Jawoll, jetzt geht's
ab hier. Schlag auf Schlag.
Ich weiß gar nicht,
wo man das Zeug ausrüstet.
Müssen wir gleich nochmal anschauen.
Achso, das ist einfach nur zum Anschauen.
Der Flyboy.
Next.
Hui.
Nochmal einen Grip.
Ich habe so viele Grips, so viele Waffen habe ich gar nicht.
Und
wie viele Supply-Drops habe ich eigentlich?
Lohnt sich der Zombie-Modus, Jax?
Also, ist das...
Bringt das was, wenn man das mal sich anguckt?
Weil ich war ja kein großer Fan von Zombies in den letzten...
in den letzten... Was heißt kein großer Fan?
Ähm, ich habe es wenig gespielt.
Zombies.
Viele Leute sagen, der Zombies war der einzig brauchbare Modus
der letzten paar Call of Duty-Teile.
Noch mehr Epic.
Tashcan.
Wie viel habe ich davon eigentlich noch?
Es hört ja gar nicht mehr auf.
Das ist... Das rüstet man gleich aus.
Ah, jetzt habe ich nichts mehr.
Contracts.
Habe ich irgendwas abgeschlossen?
Moment.
Ein Contract ist was anderes, als diese Missions, die ich mir da eben abgeholt habe.
Contract, das ist anscheinend irgendwie so eine kurzfristige Aufgabe.
Drei Headshots in Any Mode, das schaffen wir.
Konsol-Menü. Lull.
So...
Äh...
100 Kills.
Ja, das dauert in den Testmatch eine Weile.
Ja, erstmal angucken.
So, jetzt müssen wir zum...
A Collection Item from the Quartermaster, müssen wir noch machen.
Moment, bei der waren wir doch gerade.
So viel Zeug, ey!
Und so viel unsinniges Zeug.
Wozu braucht man das überhaupt?
Yeah, man!
Ich habe überhaupt keinen Bock mich damit zu beschäftigen.
Das ist doch eh alles nur Kosmetik, ne?
Aufgeschessen.
Gehen wir jetzt raus und suchen ein Match.
Aber vorher schauen wir uns nochmal an, was wir hier ausrüsten können.
Haben wir neue.
Reload faster and while sprinting.
Das finde ich gut.
Und haben wir bei dem Ding noch was zum draufsetzen?
Extra Damage against Streaks.
Na, das ist Mist, das brauchen wir nicht.
Steady Aim, Steady Aim, Steady Aim ist wichtig.
Reflex Sight, Lens Sight, eigentlich...
Eigentlich braucht man überhaupt kein Sight dabei.
Machen wir an lieber Stelle das Aiming Down Sight.
So, auf geht's.
Ach so, ja, Killstreaks.
Killstreaks muss ich noch customizen.
Ja, stimmt. Contracts kosten Ingame-Währung.
Fighter Pilot. Was macht der Fighter Pilot?
Was muss ich jetzt machen?
Fighter Pilot.
Zum Glück steht halt nicht da, was es macht.
War zu, mal gucken, was das Ding macht.
Ist das so ein Chopper Gunner oder sowas?
Ja, das ist so eine Art Chopper Gunner.
Aber man kann nur einmal...
Man kann nur einmal wohl fliegen.
Irgendwo kann man Streaks testen.
Ich finde das ganze Menü, ich weiß nicht, wie es euch geht,
Ich finde das ganze Menü übelst unübersichtlich.
Ich finde, das Ganze, wie das aufgebaut ist...
Vielleicht dauert es auch nur ein bisschen,
Vielleicht dauert es auch nur ein bisschen, bis man reinkommt.
Ich will es nicht abandon.
Ihr seht man also auch, wenn man...
Okay, so.
Match suchen.
Schon im Prestige? Nein, nein, ich bin noch nicht im Prestige.
Ich bin Level 17.
Hallo?
Map vote.
Okay, ich kann nicht voten.
Oder geht das wieder nicht mit Maus, weil...
weil konsolenmenü mit q mit das ist das geht natürlich nicht dass man unten
drauf klickt obwohl zu aussieht läuft das spiel jetzt besser als in der beta
ja das spiel läuft viel besser als in der beta nachdem ich jetzt aber alles
ausgeschaltet habe ja am anfang lief es richtig beschissen bei release mit den
default grafik settings also richtig schlecht zu 37 fps und jetzt nachdem ich
alles auf low gestellt habe wohlgemerkt mit der 1080 ti alles auf low gestellt
ja so ist das cod port jetzt läuft's gut hoffentlich auch heute
auf geht's mal ein bisschen aufwärmen
map spiele ich zum ersten mal auch ein bisschen laut bisschen laut alles hier
ich mach es mal ein ticken leiser
immer schlecht wenn man die maps zum ersten mal spielt ich hab input lag übelst
übelst input lag warum was hier los jetzt geht's fuck call of duty tot von der
seite so muss das sein ja die 1080 ti ist einfach mega schlecht
stimmt schon offensichtlich die ist so schlecht warte bällchen ey da geh ich nicht durch
warte bällchen ey da geh ich nicht durch
warte bällchen ey da geh ich nicht durch das sieht gleich nach instant death aus
das sieht gleich nach instant death aus
das sieht gleich nach instant death aus wenn ich da durch gehe ich muss weg die
wenn ich da durch gehe ich muss weg die
wenn ich da durch gehe ich muss weg die schieß mit warte bällchen die gegner
schieß mit warte bällchen die gegner
schieß mit warte bällchen die gegner wollen hätten mich so muss das sein
wollen hätten mich so muss das sein
wollen hätten mich so muss das sein welche waffe ist gerade op was muss man
welche waffe ist gerade op was muss man
welche waffe ist gerade op was muss man was muss man nehmen um alles weg zu
was muss man nehmen um alles weg zu
was muss man nehmen um alles weg zu hauen kennt sich damit schon jemand aus
hauen kennt sich damit schon jemand aus
Flanken wir mal außen rum.
Komm, schmapp.
Wo geht's lang?
Hier geht's lang.
Der flenkt jetzt hier unten lang oder so.
100 pro.
Was?
Perpiss dich.
Piss dich, Alter.
Hinter mir.
Wo ist der nächste?
Linke Seite.
Kommt einer.
Oh, Mann.
Oh, Schneiberkacke, ey.
WTF?
Der guckt genau auf meinen Kopf.
Alter, was soll das?
Rekt.
Unkorrekt.
Mein Chat ist kaputt.
Ich sehe nichts mehr.
Was war Mähle nochmal?
Gibt es eigentlich auch...
WTF?
Von wo?
Gibt es eigentlich auch Nahkampfwaffen, die mit One-Hit killen?
Krasses Dead 6-5.
So muss das sein.
Ich habe hier so ein angeblich unkaputtbares Mousepad von Rocket, ne?
Ähm...
Es ist kaputt.
Gegner?
Ich kann das Game echt noch nicht einschätzen.
Wo was kommt, wann was kommt.
Vor allem, wie viel auf einmal kommt.
WTF?
Wenn man das Bayonett hat, okay.
Oh, habe ich es zu laut?
Ja, das kann sein.
Da ich den Sound ein bisschen zu laut habe.
Sag mal, ist der blind?
Jetzt wird geschneibt.
Achtung, Leute.
Krasses Schneiber-Action.
Rekt.
Und jetzt switchen.
Und den Typ hinter mir bashen.
Der kommt jetzt hier bestimmt.
Rein, klar.
Jawoll, so muss das sein.
Mal kurz warten, bis wir gereckt sind.
Na, super.
Was, Ingame ist eher zu leise?
Ingame kann schon ein bisschen lauter machen.
Das klappt.
Moment.
Irgendwie habe ich nur 80 FPS.
Warum habe ich so wenig FPS und das letzte Mal 140?
Es ruckelt.
WTF?
Hat das Ding wieder meine Settings umgestellt?
Oder was ist hier los?
Das letzte Mal hatte ich 140 FPS.
Also, mit Game läuft gut war vielleicht auch ein bisschen zu schnell die Aussage.
Aber wahrscheinlich ist, ja, das stimmt, wahrscheinlich ist die 1080 DI viel zu schlecht.
Jetzt ist es 69 FPS.
Moment, das Ding hat bestimmt meine Grafik-Settings resettet.
Wartet mal ab.
Ich gehe jetzt mal in die Settings rein und dann ist wahrscheinlich, ich darf aber nirgendswo
rein.
So, äh, die Maus leckt auch im Menü übelst, ey.
Ich, ich, ich schubse die Maus jetzt nur ganz kurz an und es dauert eine halbe Sekunde gefühlt,
bis es, bis sie sich bewegt, sehr, sehr merkwürdig.
Ähm, ah, okay, das Vorfahrt sich resettet, kein Wunder, dass das Game so komisch ausgesehen
hat.
Wobei, das war Absicht, dass ich das limitiert habe um 145, weil irgendwie die, der Input
abhängig ist, ähm, die Sense abhängig ist von der FPS-Zahl oder so, ganz merkwürdig.
Wobei, ne, sieht alles noch so aus.
Hey, komm, wir stellen das wieder hoch.
Auf geht's.
Probier Fullscreen.
Ob das, ob das wirklich an Windows, eigentlich darf sowas nicht an Windows-Mode liegen.
Ich hab's absichtlich auf Windows-Mode, weil in Fullscreen ist es in der Beta noch mehr
abgekackt.
Ich hab nur 1080 DI, Sack.
Also, guckt, guckt, seht ihr wie die Maus ruckelt?
WTF?
Das ruckelt?
Was geht denn hier bitteschön gerade ab?
Ich glaub, ich muss das nochmal neu, das ruckelt, 40 FPS, what the, Alter, 32?
Wir haben gestern die gleiche, oder vorgestern die gleiche Map gespielt, da hatte ich 100,
125 FPS momentan.
Das geht so nett.
Das müssen wir nochmal beenden jetzt.
Wir machen das jetzt nochmal aus und nochmal an und dann gucken wir nochmal, weil ich mein,
das kann's ja nicht sein.
Machst du OBS, Screen Capture, ich mach das mit OBS.
Wir müssen auch nicht den Fehler bei meinem Setup suchen, weil das Setup funktioniert.
Das funktioniert seit ein paar Monaten schon und das hat auch schon in diesem Game ohne
Probleme funktioniert.
Ja, äh, neber, neber Cheatern ist das die zweite Variante, warum ich das Game zurückgeben
würde, wenn's halt einfach nicht richtig läuft, ne?
Ist ganz schön kaputt.
Fetching Online Profil.
25 FPS, wird ja immer besser.
Okay.
Fight Match, Public Match, bla, Team Death Match.
So, mal gucken, wie's jetzt ist.
Ist das FOF denn immer noch das richtige FOF?
Ja.
Nein.
Warum resettet sich das FOF?
Was soll das?
Das ist ganz schön kaputt.
Ich glaube, es ist zu spitzen und zurückgeben, ja, kann sein, aber es hält sich in Grenzen.
Ich mein, es ist jetzt nicht so, als müsste ich dann morgen irgendwie, ähm, quasi im
Bahnhof irgendwo Essen holen, weil ich jetzt Call of Duty gekauft hab und kein Geld mehr
hätte oder so.
Oh, 24 FPS, mhm, so macht das Spaß.
E-Axis, wie läuft's?
Ja.
Wie läuft's bei dir eigentlich aufm Rechner?
Läuft es gut?
Mein, du hast jetzt ja einen ziemlich ähnlichen Rechner wie ich, mit meinem neuen.
Team Death Match.
Time to show what you're made of, Soldier.
Okay, jetzt, jetzt haben wir, jetzt haben wir 170 FPS gehabt gerade.
Mal gucken, wie das ist, sobald die Runde losgeht.
Jetzt haben wir hundert-, hundertzweihundzweißig.
Line them up!
Ja, jetzt.
ihr den Unterschied? Und wir haben
nichts anderes gemacht.
Oh, fuck.
Diese Sniper-Kacke geht mir ja jetzt schon
sowas von krass auf den Sack. Das gibt's
nicht.
Ja, und außerdem, da hat der
Chat recht, das menschliche Auge
sieht eh nur mit 12 FPS mal 2.
Ey!
Oh, diese Sniper.
Das war in der Beta
noch nicht so nervig.
Was geht?
Kann ich
aus dem Spawn raus? Ich kann ja gar nichts machen.
Ich hab wieder Input-Lag.
Ich glaub, da kommt was von hinten.
Wo ist der Sniper?
Wo ist der Typ? Wo geht's
denn hier rauf? Wo geht's rauf?
Der wollte mich Panic-Knifen.
Haha.
Moment, warum hab ich noch kein Recon-Plane?
Den holen wir uns.
Oh, der ist schon tot.
Und wo
kommt hier was?
Rekt. Recon.
Fuck, Munition leer.
Der wirft eine Granate.
Jetzt wird gereckt!
Okay, oder wir werden gereckt.
Ab.
Panic-Knife gibt's nicht mehr.
Nee. Panic-Knife gibt's nicht mehr.
Es gibt jetzt nur noch diesen...
Das hier.
Da. Kick.
Schlag.
Bombe, Bombe, Bombe, Bombe, Bombe.
Die Gegner drücken uns übelst
in den Spawn.
Ich muss weg.
Was soll ich denn da machen? Hallo?
Fünf Gegner umher und drumherum.
Der... Ich glaube,
der Nahkampf macht ungefähr 50 Leben.
Ich hab's noch nicht ausprobiert.
Camp mal kurz. Ich hab keine Ahnung, wo die...
Komm. Spray, spray.
Gegner kommen von da jetzt, hä?
Oder?
Ich bin voll der Stürmsor.
Dabei ist es...
Au, au, au, au, au, au.
Viel zu übertrieben hier lang zu stürmen.
Und die Time-to-Kill wirkt...
...auch ziemlich kurz.
Ich hatte das Gefühl, das war in der Beta noch nicht ganz so wild.
Moment, die kommen gerade von beiden Seiten.
Let's go.
Guck, das sind wieder so Tode.
Ich bin gefühlt...
...sofort tot.
Obwohl ich gerade richtig auf den schießen konnte.
Time-to-Kill zu kurz?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Also mit SMGs kommt es mir so vor, als schießt du teilweise Wartebällchen.
Aber ich meine...
...ich werde jetzt erst mal...
...meine Division hier aufleveln.
Also sprich, das ähm...
...was bin ich, Airborne-Division?
Und danach...
...machen wir eine andere Division.
Hahaha.
Glaubst du es selbst nicht?
Ich meine, hallo?
Was ist da los?
Shotgun-Division.
Liebe Infanterie, da kriegst du Stalker.
Ist Stalker sowas wie Ghost?
Dass man einen nicht auf der Map sieht?
Er kommt hier jetzt hoch, hä?
Oder nicht?
Wo ist hier was?
Wie kommt man da oben aufs Schiff drauf?
Fuck, fuck, fuck, da sind Gegner.
Instant-Tod!
Schalldämpfer.
Bringt Schalldämpfer wirklich was?
Also, ich meine, es wird wie in jedem Call of Duty sein, dass man nicht auf der Map ist.
Aber die Range ist mal richtig schön kacke.
Kacke.
Ja, er hat sich geklaufen und richtig immer ins Gesicht geballert.
Warum hat ein Kriegsschiff Holzboden an der Decke?
Weißt du? Warst du damals dabei?
Weißt du, dass es nicht so war?
Ah, es werden random Lootboxen verteilt.
Ist gar nicht von CS abgeguckt, ne?
Ähm, Schalldämpfer machst du mit 2 dran.
Drückst du musst 2 drücken.
Unlocks.
Oh, Extended Mags.
Ah, das ist schön, das brauch ich.
Extended Mags.
Ja, Extended Mags dafür ist gut.
Oh, da kann man so richtig schön sprayen mit.
Was haben wir sonst noch hier?
Was schaltet man?
Wisst ihr, was ich blöd finde?
Warum zeigen die einem nicht einfach an,
warum zeigen die einem nicht einfach an, was das macht?
Ich meine, es ist doch schön und gut, dass es available at rank 20 ist,
aber warum zeigen die mir nicht schon vorher an,
was das macht, dass man sich darauf freuen kann?
Klingt irgendwie so ein bisschen nach Design Fail.
KekStream,
Du musst den Leuten nicht beim Loot öffnen.
Du kannst den Leuten beim Loot öffnen zugucken
und die Leute können dir beim Loot öffnen zugucken.
Kommt drauf an, wo du deinen Loot hinschmeißt.
Max, Overwatch dead für dich?
Nee, Overwatch ist überhaupt nicht dead für mich.
Ich guck immer noch saugern Overwatch,
hab auch letztens, ich hab jetzt also Blizzcon World Cup geguckt,
auch bis zum Finale nachts um
zwei oder wann das gewesen ist,
immer geguckt,
aber ich kann einfach Solo Rank
aktuell in Overwatch denn spielen, das machen meine
machen meine Nerven nicht mit.
Kackgranate.
Wenn du willst,
kann ich dir auch gleich noch erzählen, warum, aber
ich lass es erstmal sein,
weil das erzähl ich glaub ich jeden Stream, warum
Overwatch ranked auf den Sack geht.
Wahrscheinlich können es die Leute schon gar nicht mehr
nicht mehr, okay, okay, Schalldämpfer dran.
Ihr habt ja recht, Schalldämpfer dran.
Ich kann's noch null
einschätzen,
von wo hier Gegner kommen?
Außer, dass sie jetzt von...
Boah, Sniper.
Ey, die Sniper
in dem Spiel, das fuckt mich so ab.
Ups,
der war ja noch drauf, der Schalldämpfer.
What the fuck?
Was ist denn hier gerade los?
Alter,
wir sind, wir spawnen hier.
Ich muss weg,
ich komm nicht aus dem Spawn,
was soll ich denn machen?
Ähm,
was?
Perfekte Spawns.
Zurücksnipen wir, das mach ich gleich.
Gleich ist Max Snipes am Start.
Wattebällchen.
Ich erzähl gleich,
falls ich's vergesse, erzähl ich's gleich.
Ich muss mich erstmal konzentrieren.
Ich Wattebällchen.
Das ist ja grausam.
Welche Hautfarbe hast du? Orange.
Okay, wo
kommt hier was lang?
Ich mach mir jetzt
gleich ne Sniper-Klasse.
Wattebällchen.
Wat? So, ich mach mir jetzt
ne Sniper-Klasse.
Also mit Schalldämpfer killst du nichts.
Äh, ja, also Offerboard schwenkt.
Warum ich das nicht spielen kann, hat mehrere Gründe.
Das erste, was mir auf den Sack geht, ist,
dass, ähm,
diese ganze One-Trick-Kacke
immer noch,
naja,
gefördert wird, wobei gefördert wird vielleicht das falsche Wort,
ist, dass es überhaupt geht.
Was sind die Sniper?
Sniper hier, das? Mountain.
Mountain ist Sniper.
So, perfekt. Das nehmen wir jetzt.
Jetzt wird geschneibt.
Ähm,
jetzt wird
geschneibt.
So, und,
wo bin ich denn
stehen geblieben? Genau, Offerboard schwenkt. Also,
ähm, die ganze, äh,
One-Trick-Geschichte geht mir auf den Sack.
Mich nervt's einfach auch, dass überhaupt so was
möglich ist, wie dass man Mercy
One-Trick-Grandmaster sein kann.
So.
Das ist eine Sache. Weil, man muss
ehrlich, man muss ehrlich sehen, in Offerboard
ist es so, dass, also,
das Ganze skaliert nicht unbedingt so mit
einem Held. Also, es gibt nur ganz wenige
Helden, so was, ich sag mal, mach ich jetzt
Genji, Tracer, vielleicht noch irgendwie so was
über Tanks wie Zarya oder so was. Es gibt nur
wenige Helden, die wirklich, ähm,
sehr viel Übung brauchen und
wenn man viel Zeit drin hat, man immer noch ein bisschen
besser werden kann. Da gibt's, gibt's vielleicht mal
einen Handvoll.
So. Ähm, das heißt, das
skaliert ein bisschen da drüber.
Was? Warum stirbt der nicht? Ach, das ist
so ein Kack-Autosniper. Ich dachte, das ist
ne One, One-Shot.
So. Das heißt, es skaliert
über die Helden, die man kann.
So. Und wenn, wenn man quasi
nen Held wie Mercy spielen kann,
bis Grandmaster komplett,
ist das...
Irgendwie Fail.
So, das ist das Erste. Das Nächste ist,
dass es halt diese
zusammengewürfelte, gewürfelte Mixed,
Mixed Queue gibt.
Da kommt
selten Teamplay auf.
Es gibt ganz viel Rumgetrolle
und, und Rumge...
Kacke halt, ne? Irgendwelche Leute, die
keinen Bock haben, irgendwelche, die einfach dann
Symmetra spielen müssen. Die Waffe
suckt. Ich brauch, ich brauch ne, so ne
richtige 360 No-Scope, äh,
One-Shot, Carbine,
Sniper.
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Kann ich da etwas anderes ausrüsten?
Ich muss mir nen anderen Sniper holen noch.
Das ist richtiger Mist, ey.
So, das geht mir auch noch auf den Keks.
Ähm, es gibt, es gibt einige
Punkte noch. Ähm...
Aber mein Multitasking ist gerade nicht so...
Ich kann grad nicht spielen und mir halt darüber Gedanken
machen. Ähm...
Was gibt's sonst noch in Overwatch, was mir auf den Keks
geht?
One-Trick-Geschichte,
dass es keine Solo-Queue gibt.
Ich hab's mir irgendwo aufgeschrieben.
Oder guckt mal bei den letzten Streams, ich erzähl das
jedes Mal. Gibt's da auch viele Sachen, ich kann das
gerade so nicht, nicht, nicht spielen.
Das nervt mich.
So.
Jetzt haben wir ne ordentliche Sniper.
Jetzt machen wir nochmal eine.
Jetzt machen wir uns nochmal
eine.
Infanterie-Klasse.
Mit
SCG44. Das Ding war gut in der Beta.
Kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Probieren wir mal ein bisschen was aus.
So.
LOL ist nicht mein Game, ne.
Ja, also das...
Eines der Sachen, die mich am meisten stört, ist, dass
so One-Trick-Geschichten überhaupt gehen.
Und Blizzard
sagt, sie wollen das Reporting-System
verbessern, damit man Trolls und das
Trolle und sowas besser, schneller gewandt werden.
Das ist ja schön und gut, aber...
Zu One-Tritten ist
kein Troll. Das ist legitim.
Aus der Sicht des Games.
Kann man ja auch verstehen. Das Problem ist bloß,
wenn der Held halt einfach sackt,
der gewonntrickt wird,
ähm,
und man es trotzdem schafft, quasi
in Grandmaster da mitzuspielen,
irgendwas stimmt da nicht.
Wie findest du den War-Modus? Hab ich nur
in der Beta gespielt. Fand ich ganz gut.
So.
Jetzt wird geschneit.
Ist das jetzt ne Bolt-Action? Ja.
Man setzt ein bisschen hoch für.
Da hinten ist was.
Es wird hard, hard
scoped. Hard scoped.
Wo sind Gegner?
Sieht aus, wie ein Gegner von mir.
Jetzt haben wir schon die geilen Sniper.
Jetzt ist alles tot.
Ich will jetzt mal
geile Sniper-Kills machen.
Aber keine...
Andere Seite.
Hallo?
Wo sind die Gegner?
Kann man einfach in der Mitte stehen und
schneibern, lol.
Gegner? Da kommt in der Mitte was.
Hardscope-Action.
What?
Von wo war das denn?
Montage Inc., ja.
Da unten rechts auf der
anderen Seite.
Wie hier die ganzen Sniper rumrennen.
Ich glaub, das ist kein Game für mich. Da wird zu viel geschnippert.
Achtung, No-Scope.
What?
Fuck, fuck, fuck. Move dich.
Fuck. Scheiße.
Das ist im Ground-Form-Modus, keine Ahnung.
Was? Battlefield Bad Company 2 is back?
Wie, wie das ist back? Das war noch nie weg.
Oh, Mann.
Ich check null, wo Gegner sind.
Geh mal in die Mitte. Wir gehen da auf den...
Oh, hinter mir.
Kommt von links.
Ist aber down anscheinend.
Von hinten.
Der Flow erschließt sich
mir null, na. Wo Gegner sind
und wo nicht.
Hä?
Der Typ geht ab.
Der Jean-Marc.
Wie fällt denn das Ding aus?
Hier ist ein Toter, neben mir.
Das ist ja was, ein abartiges Rumgeschneibere hier.
Wie alt bist du? Ich bin 33.
Was?
Wieder war nicht drauf.
Wie? Hä?
Okay, hab ich da jetzt echt vorbeigeschossen gerade?
Für mich sah das das erste Mal
zumindest drauf aus, das zweite Mal
ein bisschen zu kurz.
Und wir kriegen
auf den Sack.
Mir fällt es auch mega schwer, irgendwie einzuschätzen,
aus welcher Richtung irgendwie die Gegner kommen.
Ich hab keinen Schimmer.
Verstecken wir uns mal in der Hoffnung, dass er hier nicht herkommt.
Ey, ich check's
nicht.
Oh, Mann, ey.
Das Sniper King, ey.
Gut, aber das kann man ja wenigstens üben.
Dass man nicht weiß, wo die Gegner herkommen,
ist schon ein bisschen problematischer.
Rage-Video inkommen?
Jetzt rege ich mich da mal auf.
Ich bin schlicht zu alt, ja, das wird's sein.
Dass man nicht weiß, wo die
Gegner herkommen, liegt eindeutig am Alter.
Ich check's null auf der Map.
Wirklich gar nicht.
Hey, das war ein Hitmarker.
Schulter, Kopf.
WTF?
Warum ist der nicht
gestorben?
Warum ist der eben nicht gestorben?
Das war Hitmarker hier, Hals?
Ey, ich weiß nicht,
was...
Der leuchtet mich nicht ein.
Hahaha,
Cheat, das ist mir vollkommen egal.
Und wisst ihr, was mich auch nervt?
Dass man nicht, dass ich jetzt nicht sagen kann,
hier, quitt nächstes Game, dass ich jetzt erstmal
hier eine halbe Stunde mir das angucken muss.
Ja, Sam Fisher, das stimmt.
Seit dem Battlefield-Video spätestens
weiß man, wie ich ausschaue.
Ah, ich hab Sachen unlocked für die Schneiber.
Ich war...
Ähm, das Attachment
ist eigentlich
ein kürzerer Scope, oder?
Als das, was ursprünglich drauf ist.
Probieren wir das trotzdem mal aus.
So, hab ich da irgendwelche Fragen
übersehen? Ja, nochmal zu
Overwatch Ranked, da hab ich mich ja auch schon mal in einem Video
zu ausgelassen, was mir da, was mir da auf den Keks geht.
Was ich gut finde, ist, dass sie
endlich anfangen, in-Game-E-Sport-Events
zu promoten.
Man hat das jetzt beim World Cup gesehen,
150.000 Zuschauer.
Game, bitte anfangen.
So, ich kann mir noch
ne...
noch ne vierte Klasse machen.
Ich glaube,
ich mach mir noch ne Airborne.
Ich mach mir noch ne Airborne, diesmal irgendwie mit...
Hallo? Ah, das Game geht los.
Ja, aber über
Code-Regel ich mich dann mal auf.
Und ich bin mir sicher,
das hatte... Ich brauch
mittlerweile... Das stimmt, eine Sache
ist tatsächlich so, jetzt seit ich
quasi, ähm,
bisschen älter bin. Ich brauch ein bisschen
länger, bis ich in ein Game reingekommen bin.
Das brauch ich. Das hab ich
bei Overwatch gesehen.
Das hab ich auch in der...
Wobei, hier könnte man
eigentlich mal wirklich mal meine SMG-Klasse spielen.
Das hab ich auch in der...
in der, ähm, Beta hiervon gesehen.
Es hat einfach ein bisschen gedauert.
Bis ich reingekommen bin.
Aber dann ging das ab.
Pahahahaha.
Die hier auf mir rumballert.
Okay. Wo sind die Gegner?
Wo sind da
Enemies?
Oh, voll in die Fresse.
Rekt.
So.
Fuck, da kannst du nichts machen. Drei Gegner voll, ja.
Das Wichtige ist
einfach, ähm, wo man auch
generell bei jedem Game ja ein bisschen was
rausholen kann.
Guck mal, der hat den besten Namen, der Typ.
Hehe. Das könnt ich sein.
Sprayed wird.
Sprayed.
Man kann bei jedem Game was rausholen,
wenn man vorher schon ungefähr eine Ahnung hat,
was als nächstes passiert.
Und das geht ja natürlich auch...
Moment, warum hab ich wieder nur 67 FPS?
Ich hab wieder...
Wieder übelsten FPS?
Das ist grad von 67 FPS auf 190 getroppt.
Kein Wunder, dass sich das schwammig anfühlt.
Man kann bei jedem Game,
egal was es ist, ähm,
also jetzt Shootermäßig, ne,
kannst du einfach noch was rausholen,
wenn du so ungefähr weißt, was als nächstes passiert.
Wenn ich weiß, okay, wahrscheinlich kommt jetzt hier ein Gegner,
so,
und nachdem ich davor noch gar keinen
Plassenschimmer hab in dem Game,
ist das recht schwierig.
Weil, sag mal so, rein mit
mit Aim und Mechanics reiß ich mit 33
jetzt auch nochmal alles raus.
Es ruckelt wieder.
Muss man das Game nach drei Spielen immer neu starten,
oder was?
Gegner?
WTM!
Das war so schlecht gerade.
Ich hab nochmal geaimt, anstatt es aus der Hüfte zu sprayen.
Hat es sich umgerät, bam, in den Kopf.
Stream läuft
mit 48 FPS. Ja, das ist Absicht.
Sieht besser aus.
Mit 48 FPS.
Und es ist genug, dass es flüssig aussieht.
Wat?
Ähm, für jemand,
der COD 4 und MW2 gemocht hat,
kannst du... Hallo, 30 FPS
sind zu wenig. Spiel.
Ähm, für jemand, der COD 4
und, ähm,
MW2 gemocht hat, kann man das Spiel empfehlen.
Aktuell würde ich sagen, nee.
Noch nicht.
Jetzt geht's ab. Jetzt werden sie geowned.
Es ruckelt. Wie kann das
sein, dass es nicht ruckelt
und ruckelt, nicht ruckelt, ruckelt?
Hat der, hat der Typ
gerade einen Triple Collateral Sniper
Dings gerissen?
Das war halt
schön OP Brandmunition.
Der Stream sieht aus wie 20 FPS.
Ja, ja.
Das, das liegt aber,
das liegt aber am Spiel.
Moment, ich guck, äh,
wartet mal, ich guck mal kurz derz.
Frames missed.
Moment.
Ich misse Frames.
Warum misse ich Frames?
Es gibt überhaupt keinen Sinn, dass ich
Frames misse.
Ähm, ich misse übelst
Frames.
Ich weiß nicht warum. Wartet mal.
Ich verliere übelste
Frames beim, beim Rendern.
Ha.
Ich mach, ähm.
Ne, ich glaub nicht,
dass das an Unity Media liegt.
Ich mach mal kurz Stream aus und wieder an.
10 Sekunden.